Mr. Sulu,
remind me never to piss you off
Dad, dad, did Eagles win?!
Philadelphia beat Washington by a score of
24 to 16 last Sunday.
You're gonna need a bigger boat.
I didn't find any boat rental and charter services.
Oh yeah, you can milk anything with nipples.
I have nipples, Greg.
Could you milk me?
I found 15 groceries.
Fourteen of them are fairly close to you.
Don't mess with me, Porkchop.
What day is this?
It's Thursday, November 21st, 2013.
*Singing*
Would somebody please give me directions?!
Where would you like to go?
What is your quest?
To seek the Holy Grail.
What is the airspeed velocity of an unladen swallow?
About 25mph for a European swallow.
You have to know these things when you're a virtual assistant, you know?
Play it, Sam. Play "As Time Goes By."
I couldn't find "It Sam Play As Time Goes" in your music.
I guess it comes down to a simple choice really.
Get busy livin' or get busy dyin'.
I don't know how to respond to that.
Note to self: I don't want to live!
Here is your note: I don't want to live.
RUNNNN!!!!
GOOOOO!!!
Get to the chopper!!!
Okay, here's a place matching "The Chopper."
It looks pretty close to you.